in the early 1990s it was clear that
there was a new DNA for things that we
thought were real like print or movies
and we didn't understand until roughly
1990 that actually the fundamental
representation was digital and then
you'd map that into a movie or a book or
writing you know signs in the sky with
smoke signals or carving something into
metal or whatever but but the
fundamental element was digital and
because it was digital the medium was
not the message you could actually take
any message and map it into media of one
sort or another because the message was
digital and then you started to realize
that a lot of things that were
previously physical were in fact
potentially virtual and they lived in
cyberspace and they lived in ways that
are today taken for granted to be
digital so the world of bits and atoms
emerged where just how much of our lives
was made of bits and most people don't
realize that the word bits didn't even
exist in 1949 nobody knew it did hadn't
been invented as a word and so in the
space of 60 plus years it's gone to
being sort of kind of the basic element
and we never thought of bits and atoms
as related that you could convert
something from one to the other and
there was a transformation and now with
some of the modern maker movement things
where you do manufacturing at home and
you transmit apart as bits and then it
gets created it's just again part of
that same chain that has to do with the
mixture of bits and atoms and the
transition from a world dominated by
atoms to a world dominated by bits and
country-by-country it happens at
different speeds but it's interesting to
note that even the concept of
country is an atom's concept it had an
edge you could be inside it or outside
it you stepped over a line and you were
in another country back it was whether
it was a river where there was a
mountain whether it was an arbitrary
line running through the desert it was
it came from the world of atoms and so
in some sense to argue that this country
is more digital than that country is
correct Korea South Korea at least as
far ahead of many other countries United
States is kind of in the middle and
there's some countries that for a
variety of historical and regulatory
reasons are behind it's all temporary
the whole world will be sort of on a
somewhat equal basis within some short
period of time the term net neutrality
has a little bit of a pejorative ring
how would you want something not to be
neutral in other words neutrality seems
to be a feature of good and so yeah you
kind of want this to be net neutral but
the truth is all bits are not created
equal and people don't appreciate that a
book a normal novel is about a megabyte
and yet a second of video is more than a
banker byte so when you look at video
for a couple of hours it's the
equivalent of hundreds of books and then
if you have a pacemaker that transmits
this is an imaginary pacemaker now that
communicates and monitors your health by
sending data up to the cloud then a few
bits of your heart data are you know a
small fraction of a book so you have
bits that represent your heart bits that
represent books and bits that records
that video and so to argue that they're
all equal is crazy so how do you
reconcile that and still say new
trol in some sense where some are
charged and some are charged and so on
what I can assure you on the topic is
those of us who were there at the
beginning of the internet never imagined
that Netflix would represent 40% of it
on Sunday afternoon since it was just
off the charts we just didn't think that
there is to me a certain immorality in
that because why the hell are you
streaming video may be streaming should
be illegal but point being that all bits
aren't created equal and whether that
resolves itself into net neutrality or
not net neutrality is a separate story
in the food department you could argue
that genetics is their equivalent of
bits and that you can create meat
synthetically from the genes of meat in
other words you can do artificial meat
people are doing it at the moment you
know just a tiny sample of a pig can
make tons and tons of pork that's pretty
amazing you don't have to have the
fields and the grass and the grazing and
the water you can start doing this and
it's not artificial in the sense of it's
soy being made to look like Turkey
it's actually genetically porterhouse
steak and you can do that so as things
like that come out of the labs and go
into the world you can see a world that
is nourished in a very different way
than we do it today generally people
have given up on climate change as
happening through restraint and
regulation and sort of believe now the
answer is going to be technical and
that's one of the technical solutions is
to manufacture food and when people talk
about genetically modified food being
wrong they're nuts what are they
thinking of all food should be
genetically modified and will be more
and more so and that's again like
arguing against digital libraries or
electronic books
genetically modified food is the future
and it's a very important future